llega el momento de repasar la prensa
internacional esto con rosa pérez masdéu
rosa feliz mañana de jueves abrimos esta
revista de prensa con información que
está en portadas en todo el mundo y es
que según la acnur como ya también
estábamos adelantando nuestros
noticieros ya son un millón de personas
las que huyen de ucrania a una semana de
esta invasión por parte de rusia vamos a
ver como lo titula el espectador de
colombia rosa bueno es tierra del
exactamente como comentabas esta
información pues la encontramos en
portadas internacionales de los
distintos continentes como en la de este
medio colombiano 'el espectador' o
también en el periódico español el país
que titula el éxodo ucraniano camino de
ser el mayor en europa desde la segunda
guerra mundial también encontramos en el
país que acnur recordemos el alto
comisionado de las naciones unidas para
los refugiados estima que esta cifra
podría acabar elevándose a 4 millones lo
que en una población de 44 millones como
es la ucraniana representa cerca del 10
por ciento no las el porcentaje de
personas que podrían acabar huyendo del
país pero precisamente rosa también
distintos medios de comunicación como el
'new york times' señala en diferencia
del trato por parte de la unión europea
hacia las personas refugiadas de
distintos orígenes pues ya también lo
habíamos conversado esto con más romeros
a la hay racismo rosa pues precisamente
lara jakes en el new york times escribe
an respecto a esto europa abre las
puertas a los refugiados ucranianos que
estuvieron cerradas para otros y
particularmente jakes hace referencia a
países como polonia hungría y austria
pero la cuestión es que no hace falta
irnos a países europeos con un discurso
xenófobo tan abierto sino que recordemos
que simplemente en las fronteras del
mediterráneo las fronteras exteriores de
la unión europea cerca de 24.000
personas han muerto intentando no llegar
a territorio europeo según la
organización internacional de las
vibraciones y europa pues no hace nada
al respecto ni tampoco se lamenta de
estas cifras raúl pero hay muchos países
donde se puede ver
giro en la retórica respecto a los
refugiados ucranianos en comparación con
refugiados de otros países pero nos
queremos fijar precisamente en el caso
del presidente francés emmanuel macrón
porque ayer se dirigió al su pueblo a
francia para hablarles no de la
situación en ucrania y les comento lo
siguiente
y
nos estamos organizando y acogeremos a
todos los que lleguen a nuestro suelo y
los protegeremos francia también hará su
parte acogiendo los niños que se han
visto obligados al exilio y se han visto
separados de sus padres los protegeremos
bien raúl y en referencia a este
discurso que dio ayer el presidente
francés precisamente bfm esta televisión
de francia pues titula lo siguiente no
una frase un extracto de este discurso
francia pues a tomar a su parte no hará
lo que lo que tiene que hacer para
acoger a estas personas macro no habla
de proteger a los ciudadanos ucranianos
pero hemos querido comparar esta
retórica con la que tuvo el presidente
francés el 17 de agosto dos días después
de que los talibanes tomaran a la
capital de afganistán kabul en ese
momento como vemos aquí en esta
información de 'france info' macro na
dijo que quería proteger europa de los
importantes flujos migratorios
irregulares y aquí utilizaba la palabra
proteger de una forma completamente
opuesta no protegiendo europa de
personas que huían de la guerra o del
nuevo gobierno de afganistán del
gobierno talibán aquí utilizando la
palabra proteger de una forma
criminalizadora hacia estas personas
como si su pulso si eran una amenaza
para la población de europa y
precisamente este contraste lo recogen
también dos viñetistas uno de mediapart
see if la vita banana del país en las
siguientes viñetas que hemos querido
seleccionar no sé si las podemos ver en
todo caso ahí está no durante este
tiempo en la tele comenta así refugiados
inmigrantes personas racializada
migrante no irregular la persona blanca
con la con el pañuelo de ucrania pues
una refugiado nos sepan al reconocerlas
y en el otro caso flavi está banana en
el país dice estamos todos en el mismo
barco
y aquí en una en una balsa no pregunta
nosotros también hemos dicho pues barco
no balsa nos patera como se dice en
español pero raúl para terminar con este
tema porque esta diferencia pues bueno
una de las fuentes académicas que hablan
en ese artículo del new york times al
que nos referíamos al principio señala
es difícil no ver que los ucranianos son
blancos cristianos y europeos no entra
un juego la xenofobia como con los
refugiados de oriente medio o áfrica y
es que es importante dejar claro que
aquí no se está criticando la forma que
la unión europea pues plantea la acogida
de las personas refugiadas al contrario
sino entender que lo que es realmente
una amenaza es el racismo pues en las
políticas hablando de doble mural rosa
el polémico medio ruso rt en inglés
publicado un artículo señalando que eeuu
nunca ha sido sancionado por empezar una
guerra porque pues exactamente aquí una
primera cosa señalar en este artículo de
russia today si se habla de guerra y de
invasión
precisamente dicen consideren el ejemplo
más notorio la invasión de irak en 2003
esta desastrosa guerra que los medios
occidentales consideraron un fallo de
inteligencia representa una de las
agresiones no provocadas más atroces de
los últimos tiempos una guerra en la que
acabaron muriendo lo cierto cerca de un
millón de personas raúl gracias a rosa
entonces por esta información pasamos
ahora a saludar a nuestra primera
invitada del día gracias rosa